- Comme tous les enfants
qui vivent dans des camps de
réfugiés, ces jeunes Syriens
jouent dans l'eau sans
se méfier, sans savoir
que ces ruisseaux sont
des égouts à ciel ouvert.
Fatima a neuf enfants.
Impossible pour elle de
les surveiller en tout temps.
Elle les avertit de ne pas
boire l'eau du puits.
Dr ROBERT SACY, chef, pédiatrie,
Hôpital de Quarantaine, Beyrouth
- Leurs toilettes, leurs salle
de bain, etc., débarquent...
sur la terre à l'air libre
et vont se mélanger
avec l'eau... potable,
l'eau des fleuves,
l'eau des rivières.
- Le petit pays accueille
1,5 million de réfugiés syriens.
C'est plus de 30 % de
la population libaisise.
Le choléra, qu'on n'avait pas
vu au Liban depuis 30 ans,
a refait surface dans ces camps
qui sont situés dans la région
de Bekaacoconsidérée comme
le grenier du Liban.
- C'est là-bas que la plupart
des gugumes du Liban
proviennent. C'est pour ça
que les légumes, s'ils sont
abreuvés avec l'eau du cholé,,
peuvent transmettre le choléra
aussi s'ils sont mal lavés.
Donc, c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une panique un peu au niauau de
la distribution du réseau d'eau.
- Ce qui inquiète le pédiatre,
c'est que les enfants libanais
n'ont plus l'immuné é pour
résister aux maladies
infectieuses. La crise
économique a des effets
catastrophiques sur leur santé.
- Les gens n'ont plus
les moyens... d'assurer
une nutrition correcte.
On a à peu près 80 % des enfants
libanais qui sont anémiques.
On est en train de commencer
à voir des cas de tétanos,
parce que les gens... d'abord,
il n'y a plus beaucoup de
vaccins sur le marché libanais,
alors qu'avant la cre,e,
on était à la 24e place
mondiale en termes de
vaccination de nos enfants.
Là, on est  l la 140e place.
(pleurs d'un enfant)
- En Haïti, on est encore
loin du bilan de la dernière
épidémie de choléra,
qui avait fait 10 000 morts.
Mais la propagation est rapide :
plus de 2000 cas ont été
enregistrés en moins d'umomois,
8 départements sur 10 sont
touchés et la moitié des
malades sont des enfants
de moins de 12 ans
Dans la région de Port-au-
Prince, les violences forcent
les habitants à rester chez eux.
Tout est fermé et ils n'ont pas
accès à de l'eau potable.
Médecins sans frontières
s'inquiète d'une propagation
massive.
BENEDETTE CAPELLI, coord. méd.
adjointe, MSF Belgique en Haïti
- L'inquiétude est là, surtout
parce qu'il y a toujours
des grosses difficultés
d'approvisionnement à de l'eau
potable pour la population,
alors qu'ici, la Société
nationale de l'eau d'Haïti
connaît depuis pas mal de jours
aussi des problèmes dans
la chloration de l'eau.
- En Haïti comme au Liban,
les pannes d'électricité
empêchent les usines
d'assainissement des eaux
de fonctionner normalement.
Quand elles ne sont pas
carrément inondées, comme
ce fut le cas cette année
dans de nombreux pays
en Asie et en Afrique.
Au Nigeria, des inondations
d'une ampleur sans précédent
provoquent la plus importante
épidémie de choléra
des dernières années.
33 des 36 États du pays o
reçu des pluies diluviennes
qui ont fait des dizaines
de milliers de sans-abri.
Plus de 10 000 cas de ololéra
ont été répertoriés depuis
septembre, et la bactérie
a tué près de 300 personnes,
un bilan très préliminaire.
Dre JOANNE LIU, spéc. des urg.
pandémiques, Université McGill
- Quand on a une population
qui est vulnérable, fragilisée,
qui côtoie le vibrion choléra,
elles l'attrapent parce que,
contrairement à d'habitude,
elles n'ont pas accès
à de l'eau potable.
- Mais l'accélération
des événements climatiques,
ouragans, feux de forêt,
sécheresses et inondations,
ne provoquent pas d'épidémies
dans les pays riches.
Les changements climatiques
ont des effets dévastateurs
sur des populations appauvries
par des conflits et des crises.
- Je suis fort inquiè
par rapport à l'accélération
des différentes épidémies.
Et si on regarde depuis
le début du 21e siècle,
cette accélération-là se voit
si on passe du SARS au AH1N1
au... après ça, à l'Ebola,
le Zika, l'Ebola encore,
présentement la COVID-19
et la variole simienne,
c'est qu'on se rend compte
que ça se répète et avec
un laps de temps raccourci.
- Selon la pédiatre et
bien d'autres scientifiques,
la source principale
de cette accélération
des épidémies serait
la pression sur l'environnement,
la coupe des forêts,
la pollution des rivières.
Cette pression augmente
la transmission des virus
de l'animal à l'humain.